Hello everyone, I'm Robin Templeton and I'm going to talk about EMAX Beguiled and recent
progress on the GAL EMAX project.
First of all, if you're not familiar with GAL, it's an implementation of the Scheme
Programming Language, which is a dialect of Lisp, and the same family as EMAX Lisp, and
GAL is Gadoo's official extension language.
The goal of the GAL EMAX project is to use GAL as the basis for EMAX's Lisp support,
so it has two main components, a new EMAX Lisp compiler built on top of GAL, and a variety
of EMAX in which the built-in Lisp implementation is entirely replaced with GAL ELisp.
We expect the combination of these two projects to have several benefits.
One is improved performance, another is increased expressiveness for ELisp, and making it easier
to extend an experiment with the language.
And finally, it will reduce EMAX's reliance on C for two reasons.
GAL will be responsible for the language implementation, so EMAX will no longer have to include
a Lisp interpreter, and it will also become possible to implement much more of EMAX in less
than is currently feasible.
And of course, this raises the question of why GAL is suitable as part of it, and we
chose GAL for a few reasons.
GAL is primarily a Scheme of notation, but also has built-in support for multiple languages
using its compiler tower to add support for a new language to GAL.
You only have to write a compiler from the source language to Trial, which is essentially
a low-level, minimal representation of Scheme.
All of GAL's compiler optimizations occur at the Trial layer or lower, so you don't need
to worry about the lower level details of the compiler when initially implementing your
language.
GAL also has some Lisp features that are very rare in Scheme of limitations.
For example, it has a nil value, it counts as both false and an empty list, just like a
nilisp, and it also has a version of the common Lisp object system, and it's metoptic protocol,
which is called Goops.
The idea of GAL Emax has a pretty long history, going back to at least three decades, and
there have been about half a dozen previous implementation attempts.
But the current iteration began with a series of six-summer of code internships – a Daneo
Crafts in 2009, and then my internships from 2010 to 2014.
And my basic implementation strategy was pretty straightforward.
I implemented a core subset of E-Lisp, which was enough to run some batch mode programs
outside of E-MAX.
In E-MAX, I modified the garbage collector and the data structures for Lisp objects to
use their libGAL equivalents.
And our place E-MAX's Lisp evaluator with the one provided by GAL E-Lisp.
And after a little over a year of work at the end of the 2014 internship, I ended up with
a fully functional prototype of GAL E-MAX.
It used GAL E-Lisp alone as its Lisp implementation, and was completely compatible with E-MAX functionality,
and with external extensions.
And caveat was that the performance was pretty bad, as I was focused on correctness, as well
as ease of integration with the E-MAX E-code.
But it was nonetheless a major milestone for the project.
And let's take just a moment to look at GAL E-Lisp.
For starters, we have access to GAL modules.
So, if you call GAL E-Lisp version function, see that we're running under GAL E-Lisp.0.
It acts as to some of the numeric tower via the arithmetic functions.
We also have multiple values.
We have to be careful to use GAL E-Lisp procedure here.
Now, the CL libraries, you can see this works properly, rather than being an emulation.
And finally, we have tail-call elimination, and naturally we're going to use factorial
to demonstrate it.
So, if n is 0, turn the answer else or curse with n less 1, and n times a.
And of course, this definition works quickly, but it gets more interesting if we communicate
the answer with an error.
Now, we're going to look at a backtrace.
You can see here that there are no calls to a fact visible in between the request to evaluate
and the error communicate the answer.
And that's because this tail-call has been optimized into effectively go to.
And this is essential for any kind of series functional programming.
So, that's a peak at GAL E-Lisp.
In 2015, I left university to go work on web technologies, and the project was dormant
for a very long time.
But that's been changing recently.
During the last few months, I've been working with Larry Volkama to rebase GAL E-MAX onto
the development branch of upstream E-MAX, including the past decades' worth of upstream
development.
What we've ended up with is a series of rebases onto different versions of E-MAX.
The older ones tend to work pretty well.
The newer ones have increasingly bad problems, where they haven't been properly adjusted for
changes in the E-MAX implementation.
What we do have, by now, a version of E-MAX, is boosted correctly and can be used for
interactive debugging, as well as the ability to bisect the provisions of E-MAX and find
out where regressions were introduced.
So our immediate goal is, of course, to complete the rebase.
At the same time, we want to improve GAL E-Lisp's performance to at least be competitive
with ordinary E-MAX-Lisp.
Just to characterize the performance situation, GAL E-Lisp is usually about half as fast as
ordinary E-Lisp, while GAL E-Lisp is quite often in order of magnitude faster than ordinary
E-Lisp.
And that's based on micro-venge marks, like the Gabriel-venge marks.
But there's clearly a lot of room to improve our compiler's output.
If you want to mark your calendars, we're expecting to have a usable version of GAL E-MAX
already out sometime next spring.
We're also going to put some effort into either extracting all the work or doing new work
that could be contributed upstream.
On the GAL side, we'll probably start out with optimizing the dynamic binding facilities,
which are used very seldom in-skim, but are used all the time in traditionalist bi-lex.
On the E-MAX side, we'll be working initially on abstracting away the details of the
list implementation, where they're not relevant, and that will clean up the E-MAX code based
a bit.
It'll make it easier to integrate E-MAX and GAL E-Lisp, and it will probably be helpful
for anyone who's working on ordinary E-Lisp on their own.
We're also going to be adding new features to E-MAX, as we've seen in a few of them already.
The numeric tower, tail co-optimization, common-less compatibility, we're also going to provide
access to fibers, which is a GAL library based on ideas from concurrent ML.
That provides much more powerful facilities for concurrent and parallel programming than
what E-MAX currently offers.
And, this plan meets GAL E-MAX's basic goals, and it's work that we could maybe get integrated
upstream in a reasonable amount of time.
But it's also worth considering what more we can do, and what effect GAL E-MAX might
have on E-MAX, if it becomes simply E-MAX.
For context, the amount of C-Coded E-MAX has increased by around 50% in the last decade,
and it now constitutes around the quarter of the code base.
And C can be a bit of a barrier to customizing and extending E-MAX.
For example, there are about 1,500 C subroutines.
Around 500 are used in C-Code, as well as available to list code.
And being written in C means that they can't be practically redefined.
The use of C can become a barrier to extending E-MAX or customizing its behavior.
So we might consider writing as much of E-MAX as possible in Lisp, and one way to speed up
this process would be to provide a common list implementation for Kyle.
Note that between GAL E-Lisp and GAL Scheme, we have all of the essential ingredients for
a common list environment.
We can also share code with other common list implementations such as SPCL and SICL.
And for all, the duration of the project would be better measured in months or even years
despite common list reputation for being a large language.
This could have multiple uses, of course.
It could be a model for future improvements to E-Lisp, because E-Lisp and CL can interact
directly without problems.
And it would be very easy for E-Lisp to borrow language features from common list.
But for the purpose of a C to Lisp transition, it would also provide us with instant access
to a huge number of high quality libraries for things that GAL is not necessarily equipped
to deal with, such as access to low-level Windows APIs, as well as lots of other libraries,
such as interfaces to GUI toolkits for a variety of operating systems.
And at a certain point, this has technical advantages.
If most of E-Max is written in Lisp, then we could consider using GAL Hoot to compile E-Max
to WebAssembly, making it available perhaps in web browsers or on systems with the WebAssembly
system interface.
But it would also be a great victory for a practical software freedom.
Let's see idea that, free of one, the freedom to study and modify programs, should not just
be legally and technically possible, but should be actively encouraged by a computing environment.
E-Max is really one of the archetypal examples of this, but we can and should go further.
When E-Max is implemented primarily in Lisp, the entirety of the system will be transparent
to examination and open to modification.
Every part of E-Max will be instantaneously inspectable, redefineable, and debuggable.
And this will be a fundamental change in what is possible to do with E-Max extensions.
For example, one experiment I'd be interested in is using the common Lisp interface manager
as the basis for E-Max's user interface.
Screw Lisp is giving a talk about McLean later today.
But for present purposes, just think of it as a super-powered version of E-Max's concept
of interactive functions.
It would be a pretty long-term project, and E-Max is currently exists, but it would be
almost trivial if E-Max were customizable at the lowest layers via Lisp.
And we'll certainly be looking at the practicality of these kinds of changes as we continue developing
Gali-Max.
Finally, how can you get involved with and support Gali-Max?
One way to help is just by trying it out and letting us know what your experience is like.
There will be a snapshot available on the code-bird project site of the version that
I'm using to give this presentation.
It will be available both as a geeks package and as a portable tarball.
This will be more interesting as we get closer to a complete rebase.
We're also always happy to talk to potential contributors or potential collaborators from
other projects.
We can always use bug reports and we're interested in what kind of features people actually want
to see.
And Gali-Max is also being developed by a small worker cooperative.
So, donations are a pretty direct way to support the project.
If you do nothing else, I recommend going to the website and subscribing to our mailing
lists so that you can keep up with news on the project.
If you're watching this at e-max.com, there will be a Q&A session and we'll be following this.
Thanks for watching.
[Clock ticking]